okay this week's classic interview
relates to a bunch of stories that we've
been talking about there's been a
resurgence of the anti-vaxxer community
to the degree that the World Health
Organization is now listening
anti-vaccine sentiment as one of the top
ten global health threats for 2019
this is taking place in the United
States acutely in Washington State and
Oregon we also have been talking about
Donald Trump's idea of bible literacy
classes and both of these issues relate
to my interview from almost four years
ago at this point with Linda Martin
Linda Martin shed incredible light on
faith healing and anti-vaccine sentiment
on religious child abuse and a whole
bunch of other horrible stuff that it's
important for us to know about and it's
particularly disturbing because Linda
Martin was part of one of these
communities in the northwest of the
United States where we are now seeing a
measles outbreak because of anti vaccine
sentiment so let's get to that classic
interview with Linda Martin from 2015
we've been following the string of faith
healing deaths in Idaho and here to talk
to us about that and the connection to
the followers of Christ Church is Linda
Martin of former followers of Christ
Church member Linda it's really great to
have you on I think for people who are
not familiar with the followers of
Christ let's start there how would you
characterize that church
okay the followers of Christ is
basically a fundamentalist Christian
sect and one of their beliefs is they
believe in faith healing over modern
medicine their only form of medical
treatment for illness and injury is
prayer and anointing with oil okay and
how did you first were you born into the
followers of Christ Church did you join
as an adult I was born into the
followers of Christ actually my
ancestors were instrumental in starting
the followers of Christ and I'm sorry so
your ancestors were involved in the
creation of that church and
you grew up you started to see that
there was significant risk to
individuals as a result of the the faith
healing I don't know if policy is the
right word but doctrine nevertheless yes
as I was growing up I never was really
comfortable with the church and its
beliefs and so I left at sixteen and
talked to us about how the faith healing
is introduced in other words when people
read about a church that has a doctrine
of faith healing by prayer and oil
anointment they might wonder well is
that something that is handed out on a
pamphlet for people to read are their
sermons where people are aggressively
told that they are not to see regular
what I guess we would call Western
doctors how is this doctrine presented
to the followers it's pretty much
presented in their sermons what the
followers are taught and I heard this I
remember hearing it when I was four
years old that medicine and doctors are
a temptation from Satan and to give in
to medicine and to use medicine is a
sign of weak faith and giving in to
Satan were there threats of punishment
or X pulsation from the church if one
was to just go see a regular doctor you
don't really get threats but if you do
see a doctor it's well known that you
will be shunned my brother actually
sought medical treatment after 63 years
of being in the church and when he
started receiving medical help the
church elders came to him and asked him
to quit attending church and is there a
line that that exists with regard to
what constitutes a violation of this
faith healing doctrine in other words
the one my producer and I stopped talked
about was if someone were to to need
glasses and you go to an ophthalmologist
for an eye exam and you get glasses is
that not a medical intervention in my
opinion it is a medical intervention and
the eyes of the church the way they see
as dental work and glasses do not
prolong your life and the way they see
it is medicine can save a person's life
it can prolong a person's life and
that's God's duty and to intervene with
that and to take medicine means you're
actually doing God's work when it comes
to the glasses and the and the dental
work they don't feel that this is
extending your life or saving your life
in any way so that's okay interesting so
that's how it's rationalized now of
course we know that if you're driving
and you can't see that could certainly
have a negative impact on your life but
but dental work very specifically we
know dental health is very much
connected with with life expectancy so
it's did you feel that it was sort of
kind of an arbitrary in hindsight
hindsight rationalization that didn't
make sense it's never made sense to me
I've asked people in the church for
years why it's okay to to take medicine
or to go to a doctor eye doctor or to a
dentist because when you go to a dentist
they're giving you novocaine that's
medicine you know you're taking eye
drops to dilate your eyes when you go in
and have them check that's a form of
medicine but this is okay okay let's
talk now about the faith healing deaths
that have taken place there's been this
string of them and you've described I've
read a couple of articles when where you
heard the specifics of how certain
individuals were found dead you knew
right away that it had sort of the
signature of the followers of Christ
around it so talk to us about that what
what what do you is the signature of a
faith healing death pretty much when a
coroner goes in after a follower has
died there's a series of events that
take place once a child dies the first
thing they do is they clean the body
take the clothes off and put clean
clothing on them they want people to see
that they're taking good care of their
children when they come in and see them
dead
one of the things I've always noticed as
they seem to read from a script it's
always says well the child you know had
been ill wasn't feeling good but they
seemed to be getting better so they
weren't too concerned about him and then
all of a sudden they just got really bad
and died suddenly and nobody saw it
coming so that is actually interesting
because individually when we look at the
the reports of these faith-healing
deaths some form of that is essentially
what the parents are quoted as having
said now internally when there was a
faith-healing death if you remember
bearing in mind of course that you left
the followers of Christ when you were 16
was the conversation internally
different in other words how is it how
is it rationalized and discussed not for
the purposes of the coroner or the
police that would depend on the
circumstances what I was hearing was
that the church members were concerned
about autopsies being performed they are
very much afraid of authorities coming
in and questioning their story at all
and were their very specific discussions
that led to this sort of script that you
described in other words this is how we
should talk to coroner's to prevent a
further investigation I don't know if
there's much conversation going on
between people but that's just always
what you hear you know 99% of the
children that die if you look at the
descriptions in the coroner's reports
well we thought they had the flu you
know almost all of them seem to die from
the flu was there ever a discussion
about why God wanted so many of the
children of the followers of Christ to
die I never really heard any discussion
about Hawaii it was just always when the
children died it was God's will
okay and let's let's now talk about
legislation in Idaho we have seen some
successful prosecutions of pair
who chose to faith heal what what
exactly is going on now with regard to
legislation around this okay an Idaho
they have four laws on their books to in
the Criminal Code and to in the Civil
Code and basically what they say is that
a parent is not neglecting their duty to
the child if that child dies and their
only treatment is prayer so pretty much
Idaho law is sanctioning this form of
child abuse it's quite a blank slate
isn't it if there was prayer and the
parents believe that that was a form of
medical treatment then they are
essentially exempt from from prosecution
yes Idaho has a legal defense to
manslaughter a religious defense to
manslaughter so what can what is being
done what are you trying to do we had a
bill introduced last year representative
John Gannon introduced a bill that would
have amended Idaho Code 1815 o14 which
is in the criminal code and the way it
would have amended that would have been
the parent was not negligent if they
sought spiritual means alone unless that
led to a child being permanently
disabled or death that would be a very
significant change and does it where
does that stand now what are the chances
of this becoming a real thing the way it
stands now is there's been little
movement to get that reintroduced into
the legislative session this year I'm
actually going to be going to Idaho next
week to talk to the legislators and see
if we can get another bill going forward
this year what would it make sense for
our audience to do about this who can
they call or email in the Idaho
Legislature to try to put pressure on
them to pass this the Speaker of the
House got bad key would be a good place
to start and then members of the
judiciary and rules committees basically
just any of the Idaho legislators they
need to know how serious the
and they you know they need to
understand that as long as these books
laws are in the books that children are
going to continue to die
yeah and we're seeing that certainly no
question that that is happening we've
been speaking with Linda Martin former
followers of Christ church member we've
been talking about faith healing in
Idaho Linda thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you